Open a new notebook, and I'm going to call this.
LED composition
first some background into
linear decomposition
Let me come back to the markdown file.
Suppose we have a matrix.
and we'll call this Matrix a
we can Factor this Matrix.
into two matrices lnu
now what is L? And what is you?
a
is the original Matrix?
U is the upper triangle Matrix
Which is also the solution.
When you eliminate the rows if you
get your Matrix into upper triangular form.
You have done your elimination. So this is what the
U stands for.
so you
is the upper triangular triangle Matrix
the L part which stands for lower triangle.
is the product of all of
the elimination matrices so there is
a component that is not part of
this.
formula the elimination Matrix